hey legal eagles you hear a lot about
case briefs in law school
what is a case brief why do people do
them and why do students hate them so
damn much what can you do to get the
benefits without the hassle of case
briefs well today we're answering all of
those questions and by the end of the
video you'll know exactly what goes into
a case brief and how to supercharge them
so stick around before we get into the
case brief we need to talk about law
school in general for a second law
school is taught using the case method
or the inductive approach of learning
the law through cases that have already
supposedly applied the law so for the
sake of class discussion professors
assign several cases for reading before
students get to class that can result in
having to read dozens of cases a night
and potentially hundreds of pages worth
of cases so let's start with what is a
case in the law school context I know
this might seem simplistic but stick
with me just for a second in law school
when you read a case what you're really
reading is an appellate opinion that is
after the trial or judgment in the court
below one of the parties claims that the
trial court was wrong and appeals the
decision to the court of appeals the
factual record is set you can't change
it you can't call additional witnesses
there's no additional evidence the
parties write legal briefs and after
weighing the briefs of both sides the
appellate court will then issue a
written opinion usually that's on a
narrow issue of law in theory the
appellate court summarizes the important
facts of the case but not necessarily
always and in theory they write only as
much analysis as is necessary to
adjudicate the appeal but this is almost
never the case the appellate opinions
are almost always longer than they need
to be sometimes to provide context and
sometimes because judges just like to
hear themselves talk so in law school a
case brief is a summary of a particular
appellate opinion standard advice says
that your case brief should look like
this it should start with a case
citation you should have the name of
both parties which is usually something
like Jones versus Smith
it should include the publisher of the
particular case the reporter that the
case can be found in the court that
issued the decision the year that the
opinion was published the procedural
posture of the case meaning how it got
to the court of appeal the history of
the case a discussion of where it came
from the statement of facts the
narrative story of the case the issues
that were decided on appeal the
arguments on either side the policy
implications of the different ways that
the Court of Appeal could have gone the
rule of law or the black letter law that
can be inductively discerned from the
appellate court the rationale that the
appellate court used to decide the case
and any particular dissent sir
concurring opinions that are not
necessarily the law of the case but at
least go with it so a case brief that's
the notes that you are taking regarding
the particular case regarding those
details of the case it's a summary of
the so called important parts of the
case and by the way as a free bonus you
can download our guide to case briefs
and learn how to do them the right way
in the link below but why do students do
these summaries well there are three
primary reasons the first is to learn
how to read a case standard thinking
says that the more cases you read the
more you will be able to think like a
lawyer and it's certainly true that in
practice you'll be reading lots and lots
of cases so it's a good idea to
understand what goes into a case why
judges decide the way that they do and
to be able to use cases in your practice
as both a sword and shield when you're
litigating of a particular idea the
second reason is that you need to
prepare for finals
so often you'll use cases on a final
exam obviously most of what you discuss
in class is going to be about the
particular cases that you're reading
because that's the case method itself
and so it's not surprising that you'll
use a lot of this information on a final
exam and when you're talking about an
issue spotter exam as you'll often get
in law school then you can
often use the cases that you discuss as
analogies as a way that the the court
when it's your professor shouldn't come
out and if you don't take notes on the
cases that you read and the discussion
that you have about the particular cases
by the time that finals comes around
you'll probably have forgotten all of
your cases so it's good to have a
written record of what it was that you
actually read and of course there's the
third reason which is to prepare for
class and frankly if everyone is being
honest this is probably the number one
reason you're compiling your notes so
that if the professor calls on you in
class you're able to answer their
questions about the particular case this
is the infamous cold call in law school
and it is the bane of most law students
existence it's the Socratic method to
pepper your students with as many
questions as possible until they're
simply unable to answer and any more
questions about a given subject and the
idea is that the more your questioned
about something the more you will learn
what's important and what's not and by
the way the funny thing is that when
class participation doesn't count for
anything
spending all of this time on preparing
for class instead of instead of
preparing for finals can be a bad
strategy but I get it it's terrifying to
be called on by the professor in class
so students are gonna err on the side of
reading their cases more carefully than
they might need to and taking more
copious notes than they might need to in
order to have a fruitful class
discussion but here at legal eagle we
think that most case briefing that
students do is unnecessary in a waste of
time why well because you're going to be
tested using an issue spotting
hypothetical and we have an entire video
on what an issue spotting hypo or exam
essay looks like you can check the link
below but on an issue spotter you can't
use 95% of the information that you put
in your case brief it's a waste of time
I'm sure the professor might ask about
all of that information in class but the
professor can't ask that kind of
information on the exam and the test is
what matters
and I can't emphasize that enough I've
seen hundreds of issue spotting answers
and never once did they give points for
the procedural posture of a particular
case or the history of the case or even
the rationale or the case name an issue
spotting exam makes you pretend that
you're an attorney and as in real life
you're rarely using that extra
information about a case what you are
using is the narrative story of the case
or the black-letter law that you'll find
in a case you might apply just the bare
essential meaning of what the law is but
ignore all the rest of the story or you
might use the the facts of a particular
case to make an analogy to the issue or
the the hypo that's in the issue spotter
to make an argument one way or the other
to say that this case is like the case
that you read before in that the facts
are similar or that it should come out
differently because the facts are
different but the thing is the case
brief takes up so much time it takes up
hundreds of hours and you're focusing on
generally the wrong thing we think that
instead of doing the standard style of
case briefing where you highlight your
case brief and make it look like a
rainbow with all the different colors
the highlighter and write all of those
different dozen things that you can
write about a particular case in your
case brief we think you should do what
we call a three point brief a three
point brief focuses only on the three
things that your professor cares about
and more importantly it's the only three
things that you're actually going to use
on your final exam you can learn how to
write a three point brief in our free
guide to law school case briefs and the
link to that is down below it will I
promise
save you hundreds if not thousands of
hours during your law school career and
also check out our video on how to study
for class using the flipped case method
the link for that is also below it'll
save you so much to pain in terms of
reading your cases it also as always
please click on the like and subscribe
button if you liked this video the more
people subscribe the more videos we'll
make on how to crush law school so what
do you think about case briefs did you
come up with a way of case brief
that works for you did you abandon them
halfway through the semester or have you
not started law school and you're
wondering just what the helicase brief
is let me know in the comments below and
until next time it legal eagle think
like a lawyer and ace the exam before we
get into law school in general for a
second
appellate after and after weighing legal
briefs to the party they do